souhaits de bienvenue dans la paix dans
la liberté retrouvée
c'était il ya exactement 40 ans la fin
de l' incroyable prise d'otages à
l'ambassade américaine de téhéran
52 américains diplomates et employés
ils sont retenus pendant 444 jours
retour sur cet événement majeur entre
les deux pays qui commence le 4 novembre
1979 le domaine dramatique nos viennent
de teyran plus d'une cinquantaine de
personnes de l'ambassade des etats-unis
en iran sont retenus en otage par des
centaines d'étudiants et des gardiens de
la révolution islamique
la république islamique est proclamé
quelques mois auparavant
face aux révolutionnaires le shah d'iran
dernier monarque iranien au pouvoir
depuis 1941 prend la fuite vers les
états unis et en iran arrive au pouvoir
l'ayatollah khomeini le chef religieux
devenus leaders des révolutionnaires
ce sont les partisans de l'ayatollah
khomeiny qui détiennent les otages
américains accusés d'espionnage ces
mêmes partisans qui demandent aux états
unis l'extradition du shah d'iran pour
qu'il soit jugé dans son pays
ils ne peuvent rien faire d'autre que de
nous livrer le chat et après ça nous ne
voulons plus avoir de relation avec eux
de chabacks d'atsem l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran est devenu
aujourd'hui un véritable lieu de
pèlerinage de rencontre on vient y lire
les journaux mureaux où se bousculent
les slogans contre l'impérialisme
américain et les hymnes à l'ayatollah
khomeini la ligne américaine est claire
pas de négociations en parallèle le
président américain jimmy carter lance
des pressions économiques contre l'iran
notre position doit être clair dit le
président américain
j'ai donné l'ordre qu'on cesse toute
importation de pétrole d'iran ainsi que
toute livraison de produits pétroliers à
ce pays après les sanctions économiques
l'amérique tente la libération par les
armes
opération eagle claw qui tourne au
fiasco c'est ici même que l'opération
montée par les états unis pour délivrer
les otages de l'ambassade à téhéran a
échoué deux appareils faisant partie du
commando se sont télescopés au sol bilan
huit morts et plusieurs blessés une
intervention qualifiée d'opération
cowboys par les iraniens et qui renforce
la détermination des preneurs d'otages
c'est grâce à une médiation algérienne
que les deux pays trouvent un accord les
états unis avec leur nouveau président
ronald reagan s'engage à ne pas
intervenir dans la politique intérieure
iranienne
le 20 janvier 1981 un flash spécial
ils sont libres libres après 444 jours
de captivité
d'un seul coup l'amérique a retrouvé sa
fierté des otages libérés la fierté d'un
pays retrouver mais surtout une prise
d'otage qui depuis quatre décennies
empoisonne les relations diplomatiques
entre ces deux pays
[Musique]